se você já parou para pensar que na
maioria das vezes que a gente busca uma
imagem que represente o que é
criatividade a gente recorre a uma
lâmpada acesa como se criatividade fosse
só sinônimo de lampejos de insights que
repentinamente dominam a nossa mente e
aí a gente se sente um gênio né
finalmente Eureka tive uma boa ideia mas
na verdade o que eu tenho para te dizer
é que criatividade geração de boas
ideias não é só inspiração pelo
contrário é transpiração é trabalho é
conexão Steven Johnson autor do livro De
onde vêm as boas ideias diz que
criatividade a junção de palpites
menores e ele chama isso de palpite
lento ou seja conforme a gente vai se
expondo a pessoas estímulos conversas
novos
e eles vão se conectando aos poucos como
o palpite os menores mesmo até que chega
um momento em que a ideia se torna
completa ela ganha força ela ganha corpo
ela faz sentido eu gosto muito do que
Steven Johnson diz porque eu pude
perceber isso na prática nos últimos
anos eu precisei me Reinventar diversas
vezes e precisei ser muito criativa no
meu trabalho então eu parei de esperar
que apenas em sites surgissem na minha
mente e passei a ir atrás deles para que
essas ideias pudessem se conectar e
realmente formar algo menor certo dia eu
tinha um projeto muito importante para
entregar para um cliente era um projeto
que meses de muito eu precisava ser
muito criativa eu precisava realmente
fazer diferente
Oi e aí que que aconteceu eu comecei a
enrolar os dias foram passando o prazo
Foi chegando e nada saía eu me senti
realmente bloqueada até que chegou o
momento em que não tinha mais como
esperar mais nenhum dia eu precisava
fazer eu precisava entregar aquele
projeto para o cliente e aí mesmo
estando tão em cima da hora eu sentei
para começar ver o meu computador e
comecei a procrastinar e o alternava
várias abas no navegador eu antecipava
atividades que não precisava fazer
naquele dia eu falava com pessoas no meu
comunicador e até fiquei muito tentada a
organizar uma prateleira do meu armário
que eu não tinha que fazer naquela hora
não fazer sentido nenhum com o prazo se
esgotando eu me permitiu essa
procrastinação por algum tempo Afinal eu
já aprendi que a procrastinação também é
importante ela pode refrescar
Oi e aí finalmente o projeto saiu aliás
eu tenho que te confessar uma coisa essa
própria palestra aqui eu enrolei para
fazer eu deixei para a última hora eu me
senti sem ideias e só quando eu sentei
realmente para pensar no assunto eu
entendi que sim eu tinha algo a
compartilhar Afinal eu precisei sair
muito criativa nos últimos anos para
poder me Reinventar profissionalmente e
chegar perto do meu objetivo do que eu
queria para minha carreira a verdade é
que criatividade também enfrentamento se
você não se enfrentar você não vai fazer
Pode até ser que procrastinar alguns
momentos seja importante e interessante
mas alguma hora você vai precisar sentar
e começar a fazer e nesse momento pode
ter certeza que as ideias vão começar a
ver Enquanto você só postergar nada vai
acontecer porém a gente não pode ignorar
que muitas vezes quando a gente não está
buscando ter boas ideias
é justamente quando elas surgem Por
exemplo quando você tá tomando banho
fazendo uma atividade física prestes a
dormir Provavelmente você já teve boas
ideias nesses momentos porque você não
estava buscando por nenhuma delas mas
por que será que aconteceu Você já parou
para pensar nisso nesse momento em que
você estava mais relaxado Provavelmente
o seu cérebro conector todos aqueles
pontos todas as coisas que você viu
anteriormente todas as conversas que
você teve pequenas partes de uma ideia
que acabaram compondo essa ideia é maior
eu hoje tem que ser muito criativa no
que eu faço no meu trabalho porque eu
trânsito entre muitos segmentos muitas
empresas adoro eu tô com cliente novo a
criatividade pode requerer também que
você deixe a ideia descansar o que é
isso muitas vezes o problema não é a
Gerar a ideia ela está ali começou a
ganhar forma mas você sente que ela pode
ser melhor então eu gosto de
a postar nessa estratégia de deixarem de
dormir Claro se eu tiver tempo para isso
Eu me afasto e depois eu volto para
continuar trabalhando nela e assim ela
ganha um formato muito melhor muito mais
criativo eu fiz isso nas três vezes em
que eu estava escrevendo livros a
inspiração a partir desta construção
dessas conexões chegava eu escrevia de
uma forma bruta e depois eu vou tá veja
organizava o texto enfim eu era muito
mais produtiva dessa maneira para que eu
pudesse me Reinventar na minha carreira
foi preciso ser muito criativa alguns
anos eu era funcionária de uma empresa e
essa empresa passou por muitas
transformações e muita gente foi
demitida inclusive no mesmo dia a partir
daquele momento eu perdi o rumo eu não
sabia exatamente o que eu ia fazer
profissionalmente eu já tinha vontade de
empreender de ter a minha própria
empresa mas eu confesso
E aí eu não tinha ideia do que fazer
nesse sentido a minha primeira tentativa
empreendedora depois da demissão foi
montar uma mini confeitaria na minha
casa eu comprei as formas as embalagens
os ingredientes e comecei a fazer doces
diferentes com ingredientes mais
elaborados Trabalhei na mídia social fiz
fotos bonitas mas mesmo assim o meu
projeto empreendedor fracassou a verdade
que isso acontece muitas vezes eu
poderia olhar para esse fracasso achar
que foi algo completamente negativo mas
na verdade até mesmo fracasso leva a
gente adiante Porque a partir dali eu
pude entender Que não era exatamente
daquela forma ou com aquele tipo de
produto que eu poderia empreender depois
de um tempo eu acabei voltando a
trabalhar em uma empresa e a partir dali
com ideias novas Eu também pude começar
um desejo muito grande que eu já
o que era de poder compartilhar porque
eu sabia o que eu havia aprendido vivido
enfim foi aí que eu comecei a escrever
artigos quando as pessoas passaram a
descobrir esses meus conteúdos e
começaram a interagir nele e eles foram
crescendo e eu fui descobrindo que eu
podia ser eu mesma eu vi muita coisa
interessante e incrível acontecendo a
minha carreira na verdade oito meses
depois que eu havia voltado a trabalhar
em uma empresa e começar a escrever eu
tinha tantos convites tantas demandas e
tanto feedback que eu finalmente entendi
que eu podia empreender a partir do meu
conhecimento como professora que é o que
eu faço hoje por meio de treinamentos
palestras enfim o que eu vivi antes e
foi um fracasso me levou adiante para
que eu pudesse entendeu o que eu queria
de fato fazer isso não significa que eu
vou fazer da mesma forma para sempre na
verdade eu preciso Reinventar o negócio
o tempo todo nesse sentido
o restante a gente falar sobre um
conceito conhecido como possível
adjacente do cientista Stuart kauffman
fazendo um paralelo aqui a internet que
a gente usa hoje todos os serviços
aplicativos e possibilidades que a gente
tem alguns anos não era assim a internet
é muito mais simples com menos recursos
e possibilidades porém quanto mais a
gente avança mais é possível partir de
um novo ponto para criar outras coisas
mais e a gente pode até pensar sobre
quando Santos Dumon criou o 14 Bis na
verdade ele faria o diversas vezes antes
de chegar a um modelo de avião que
realmente fosse capaz de voar todo esse
processo trouxe conhecimento e a cada
nova tentativa ele partir de um novo. Ou
seja o possível adjacente também pode
nos ensinar sobre como o processo a
construção a transpiração também
contribui para que a gente gera e boas
ideias
e quando a gente fala sobre a
criatividade outra conceito bastante
interessante é o da serendipidade que
nos ensina sobre o Saber adaptar à
penicilina por exemplo o primeiro
antibiótico do mundo amplamente
utilizado foi descoberta em 1928 por
Alexander Fleming não estava buscando
por um antibiótico mas acidentalmente
ele chegou a essa possibilidade quando
fez alguns experimentos e depois voltou
ao seu laboratório nós não podemos
Ignorar as descobertas casuais que
acontecem quando nós estamos buscando
por alguma coisa nós temos a tendência
de ignorar quando chegamos a um
resultado não esperado Mas será que isso
também não pode ser utilizado Será que
não algo interessante nesta descoberta
casual isso pode te ajudar a ter boas
ideias também um erro também torna você
único Você já parou para pensar em
quantas vezes você fez um curso teve um
emprego outra foi um evento que você
considerou o completamente perdido
e o que não te deixou satisfeito na
verdade tudo isso te trouxe até aqui a
quem você é agora e algo que você pode
fazer é de uma forma criativa construir
uma história que consiga destacar o
quanto você é o único por tudo que você
viveu estudou aprendeu enfim eu falo
muito sobre esse conceito aí Onix Store
no meu livro sobre esse assunto foi
justamente a construção de uma história
criativa sobre quem eu sou
profissionalmente que também ajudou a
destacar a minha marca pessoal
criatividade eh também ser autêntico e
ter a coragem de não agradar porque
porque quando a gente agrada
Provavelmente nós estamos criando o
mesmo o que já existe o que todo mundo
já fez nós geralmente Estamos seguindo
padrões por isso busque se conhecer
entender quem você é em um processo de
autoconhecimento olhando para dentro mas
também olhando para fora
e você pode se conectar aos momentos ao
mercado enfim para gerar coisas novas na
época dos nossos pais dos nossos avós
era muito comum que eles morassem por
muito tempo na mesma casa na mesma
cidade ou ficar sem por muito tempo no
mesmo emprego mas o cenário que a gente
vive hoje nos obriga a nos reinventarmos
o tempo todo pensar caminhos diferentes
tentar olhar para o mercado para que nós
possamos de verdade gerar boas ideias
Inovar no dia a dia por tudo isso Eu
Acredito fortemente que criatividade é
transpiração não inspiração é processo é
construção é conexão é Reinventar e se
Reinventar o tempo todo o